all right so
welcome everybody to the next session of
uh classic middle class i'm joined here
by my good friend and colleague scott
tarrouli
who some of well everybody here knows
him because you're all
regulars but just you know since we're
recording this i'm going to say
just a few words so scott is a guitar
professor at berkeley school of music
but that
you know it's it's not a sort of book
knowledge versus
actual knowledge because he's also a
touring and
studio musician he's got some albums of
his own he's
very tapped into uh the contemporary
world he's played with a lot of cool
acts and we're going to talk metal but
scott i should point out
straddles a number of different genres
and has played with a ton of people
um so he's he's my my
interlocutor for this and i'm really
happy to have him here because
we always tap his brain when it comes to
any sort of
music theory or sonic sound
structure sort of sort of questions he
knows about the tech and the gear
that that was changing over those times
anything else you want me to say about
you scott
before we help you okay
thank you so much so today our topic
is we're shifting back to some music
history stuff but we're going to talk
some philosophy
particularly you could call it the
philosophy of dividing lines what makes
things what they are so you can call it
metaphysics if you want or
you can call it you know the study of of
definition we're we're going to be
asking the question is this really metal
about some bands and some types of music
but we're going to be doing a lot of
music history stuff as well
so we're talking about american metal in
the 1970s
it bleeds over into the 1980s obviously
because it's not as if there was a
strict dividing line a curtain that came
down
on new year's eve 1980 or anything like
that
but but i think we can say that there
was there was something going on
in america in the 70s that was
influenced by
but in some respects distinct from what
was happening in the other
really important hotbed for metal which
is great
britain and so
we're going to be straying into the 80s
we're not going to talk as much about
like the glam or hair metal explosion
in the early 80s and then all the way
through the 80s in
la although we'll mention some of those
bands i want to reserve that for its own
uh session and we're not going to talk
so much about like thrash developing
um in in you know new york and in
out in california either because that's
a little bit later as well and i'm also
you know we'll mention mtv but this is a
little bit before
mtv becomes the massive
cultural influence that it became
in in the 80s right i don't remember
when mtv was actually established and
and some of the videos are you can find
videos from this time
but it didn't have the you know you
didn't have head bangers ball
and the reason they had had bangers ball
i should mention is because there were
so many requests for
like metal all the time that it was for
a little while swamping other genres
in mtv and so you know people from other
genres are like hey you need to play
more of our stuff are they so they push
the metal off into
its own little show um so you know one
one of the key questions we're going to
talk about as i mentioned
that straddles music history and
musicology and philosophy
is you know what what is heavy metal and
some of the bands scott and i
have differences on some of these bands
is this really metal some somewhere like
no this is definitely not metal some
were
totally agreed on then there's this
whole fuzzy area
is it metal or is it the larger genre of
hard rock or should it be described as
aor
or arena rock there were other terms
that were getting thrown around
geezer butler like to call black sabbath
stuff
as downer rock you know which we don't
really use that much anymore
but um you know associating it with
drinking and quaaludes and things like
that right
another key question that we're going to
talk about as well that scott and i have
kicked around a lot
is well what do you do with bands that
say that they're not
heavy metal bands but they really are
heavy metal bands you know they say no
no we're
we just play rock and roll and yet
everybody thinks of them
as as heavy metal um so we're gonna talk
about some bands
like that including blue easter cult um
scott's gonna bring in some
some insights uh you know sort of
filtering
from his conversations with buck dharma
about this and
and um i think they they are heavy metal
um even though they say they're not but
but there's you know this is an open
question that we can ask
um another topic that i think is
we should talk about is influence and
interaction with the wider
metal sphere american metal didn't come
out of a vacuum
like its own little special thing
there's all these interactions between
what's happening in the states and
what's happening in
great britain but also europe and canada
and japan
in the 1970s we also see and some of us
remember
the development of a self-conscious
identification
as you know a genre of music heavy metal
and as being metal heads on the parts of
all these different people
fans other industry people fans
so the the main groups that we're gonna
concentrate on
as solidly heavy metal that's that's
maybe the place to start but before that
a little bit of musical history
and stage setting so you know those of
you who've been with us
before we talked about like the origins
of heavy metal
and you know the difference between uh
proto metal and and like recognizable
metal in the past
what we can say is that around 1970
and throughout the early 70s there's a
new genre that emerges
and there's a lot of different
influences flowing into it you know
blues rock plays a big role
psychedelic rock um even space rock
arguably although it's kind of a
short-lived thing and
you know how do you identify it while
there's this heavier sound
there's more aggressive playing in terms
of the guitar riff in terms of what the
bass and drums are doing
um donna weinstein actually says that in
that heavy metal is one of the genres of
music in which the bass plays the most
important role
and i think that's that's that's quite
true when you look at the early bands
like black sabbath or ufo
or deep purple you know they're real the
base is
playing a really significant role there
and
another thing that kind of goes along
with this developing
genre and i think it really feeds into
this this might be a good place to take
a pause
and and you know talk about you know our
ideas on this
heavy metal has always been an underdog
as a musical
genre even even when it was on top it
was viewed as like lowbrow
music critics generally didn't like it
and in the 1970s they
a lot of music critics hated it they
were like this is her stupid people
you know these you could call it stupid
sounds for stupid people
right um and you know we know that's not
true because you you listen to some of
these
these musical compositions and they're
quite sophisticated right there's a lot
going on there
but there was a tendency for it to be a
you know a working-class phenomenon it
was an outsider kind of music and you
can say well that there's some overlap
there with punk as we're going to see
a bit later on but it was something so
it was something distinct
and so it developed a solid fan base of
people who are like
we don't really care what you music
critics think
or presumably other people we don't care
that our stuff isn't getting on the
radio much
we like this this stuff and we want more
and more of it and we'll come out to
we'll buy the albums we'll
come out to the concert venues we'll go
to the the
clubs and and bars and listen to it
we'll
um you know later on when cassette tapes
become a thing we're going to talk about
cassette tape
sharing back and forth um so
that that might be a good place to just
start the conversation
you know a lot of us don't remember the
70s that well because we're quite young
but you know we can talk about the 80s
and even
i think going into the 90s heavy metal
is still i think kind of an underdog um
genre of music so so you know scott i'd
like i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this anybody else who wants to chime in
as well
yeah i mean um it's a great point um we
were in high school about the same time
and
i've always it's not just the bands that
were the underdogs um
it was usually um even in college
um people that felt they didn't belong
you know to the school so uh to to
socially in high school or college and i
remember an artist next to me
uh he lived in the room next to me he
always had the shades drawn
and like sketched in you know just with
the lights on no outside light
and he listens to metal and um same with
some
some of my friends in high school it was
it was kind of like well nobody gets me
but these metal bands get me
and i don't know like socially it was it
was i saw this firsthand i don't know
how you feel but they always
you know um in my school there was very
few
true metalheads and you know we talked
about the jean jacket effect right
yeah you bought the jean jacket but
those are the ones that didn't fit in
with the
the chess club or the math club
or um getting invited to the parties
where they're
playing maybe you know like pop music on
the radio or what was on mtv
and i remember somebody
uh a friend of mine in 11th grade
writing
this scathing article about why do you
hate metals so much why do you hate
metal heads
and they they printed it and i remember
that
me thinking this this person i know is
kind of isolated he does feel like an
underdog he feels underappreciated
and what he actually verbalized back
then was
you know you know when i go home and put
my headphones on
this music understands me so i think
it's not just the critics that
hated it the music yeah i see the the
fans
well you know metal fans are some of the
most die-hard fans
and so i think i think that you know the
music
understanding me i think that's
something really central to it when
we talk about people identifying with um
the musicians you know like playing air
guitar became a
you know a gesture just as much as head
banging or throwing the horns
um yeah and that's sort of like you
projecting outward to
to them like i i want to be like them
but this notion of
of like being reached being understood
being incorporated into
like a relationship or a community i
think that i think that's a really great
insight
that that is part of what's going on and
and i think a lot of people looking at
it from the outside they're like why do
you listen to this
aggressive music with these awful lyrics
you know and and people could say
so you know think about um the early
black sabbath albums
you know there's this shift away from
themes about how we're gonna like fix
the world and stuff like that and
they're more like this sucks
you know i'm paranoid you know um
finished with my woman you know um
things are going bad and all these
different ways
and you don't necessarily have to be
like you know uh well you know
the whole world has fallen apart and we
have these apocalyptic visions but you
could be like this
actually does reach me where my life you
know
isn't ideal well you know if you really
think about it
um this is an odd connection but i've
always felt that the kind of connection
is kind of like the connection people
have with blues
okay right so your woman left you
um you know drinking whiskey you're all
alone
you know you know my house burnt down
but i think you're right i think in a
lot of ways um
the lyrics were were kind of gloomy in
in a lot of them in the sense that
socially people may have felt that yeah
i mean there were other motifs like we
could talk about the fantasy motif
but that's an escape from the world that
you're in right so
if we're talking about rainbow or we're
talking about
um well you know d.o afterwards um
constant stuff like that right uh uriah
he
had had quite a few themes like that i i
guess you could say
um so andy says it's amazing how the
external view is
anger aggression poor character lacking
intelligence but the truth is that
people inside the circle
yeah are generally far more sensitive
curious welcoming and intelligent than
people would think
i th yeah i think that um and then we're
going to talk about like the metal
outfit
in in a bit as being part of identity
you could think of it like a hard outer
shell protecting
a more sensitive uh inner life
that could be shared with other people
now of course you you you could have
have a bunch of metal heads that you
hang out with and they're all kind of
mean to each other that that that
happened
right oh yeah who's more metal you get
yeah exactly
yeah uh the stuff you're listening to
isn't real metal
we're going to talk about that yeah um
i i just lost my thought i was just
gonna say um well and
you know you had mentioned mtv
and then as some people say like uh
they started making metal corporate yeah
and then this is
what fans feel um there was a whole
vocabulary
associated with that right poser you
sold out
and you know and i think the fans become
hurt by that and
maybe a little more mean to
um the bands that were post new york
dolls
like poison which a party rock band to
me but
um they would just say these people
don't get it
and they would kind of feel like you
know these underground people but once
you've made it
it's kind of like the punk scene you
know hey you you used to get me
yeah yeah and then the introduction of
keyboards that we've talked about in the
past
you know uh even when maiden did it so
many people like i can't do this you
don't get me anymore
um so it's it's maybe the feeling of um
that that these people that you've never
met have abandoned you
um uh in a certain way here's here's a
really interesting comment from andy
seeing a big group of grown men cry
at an iron maiden's wasted years is a
prime example of what the music captures
for for many yeah and so um
there's a lot of stuff that kind of hits
you that way
and on the one hand there's a so again
i'm bringing up donna weinstein the
classic sociologist of heavy metal
um she talks about matt about heavy
metal identity is associated heavily
with with
masculinity and not just masculinity as
such but a certain
certain way of understanding it right
and so not crying would be
part of that but if you are going to cry
uh it's okay to cry
by being moved by metal music
not not over you know like a beautiful
sunset or
or things like that i suppose um
so let's let's shift back to this is
some great conversation let's shift back
to
the sketching the scene so we had like i
think you can
say there were six really key british
bands
that were helping to form this
this uh musical identity black sabbath
of course
central to it deep purple and led
zeppelin sometimes looked at as like the
big three
but i would say that ufo was just as
important
um and budgie in you know wales
was was very important uriah heap
occupies an interesting space
in that as well and some of these you
could say are more centrally metal but
they're all
part of that sonic scene and then there
were all these proto-metal bands that
also helped to make the scene some of
them are british some of them are
american
uh cream you know good example of a
british band blue cheer
jimi hendrix we're going to do some
speculation if we have the time about
what the metal scene might have looked
like if he hadn't died when he did
vanilla fudge mountain iron butterfly
edgar winter group
you know when you listen to these bands
you can hear the the things that are
going to go into heavy metal the
distorted guitars
the really heavy bass lines the you know
more aggressive drumming
uh the the styles of of singing getting
getting
getting brought into this they're not
yet quite metal
i mean some people want to say well
they're all metal but i i think we
should call that proto metal
and then we can talk about what happens
in the 70s so what happens in america
we have some bands that very early on
not everybody listens to but they are
part of an early metal
scene in the united states and it's not
as tight and not as
intercom communicative you can say as
what it's going to look like in the 80s
but they're they're part of it
so one that everybody brings up but very
few people listen to and i invite
everybody to
you know check them out is sir lord
baltimore they
are a new york city band new york city
is going to be an important place for
this this stuff they're formed in 68 and
they
put out their first album in 71 and
they're one of the first bands to be
described as heavy metal the term
doesn't
you know signify a whole genre at that
point or like a section in a record
store
but what they're playing really is
identifiable as
early heavy metal and you can you can
put them in they did they did in fact
tour with black sabbath
and interestingly enough the j giles
band
so you can tell already you know if
you've got black samus the j
j giles band in the same sentence people
are not all that clear about what metal
is at that point
another important band bang philadelphia
um their first really metal album is
their second album in 1972 just titled
bang
that that's worth checking out uh
there's a band called
dust that that played in in new york
city they had some albums in 71 and 72
they're best known for actually having
the guy who'd later be known as mark
ramon at that time he was called mark
bell and if you listen to their stuff
it sounds it sounds like metal right um
pentagram oh yeah big underground band
for a long time
uh in virginia they were formed in 72
they they didn't really
get any record deals which was a big
problem back then
um but they're doing metal um highway
robbery they only had one
album uh for love or money after they
did it
the record label didn't know what to do
it they were with rca and they got
dropped by them and so they just kind of
you know meandered around and eventually
broke up but that album
you know you listen to it it is metal uh
granicus i think
some people know about they're from
cleveland uh first album is in 73
and then you know we've got montrose
which not only
contains ronnie montrose but also sammy
hagar who's going to go on to play an
important role
their first album's in 73 so you see a
lot of stuff going on
and then of course kiss
and there's you know this this leads us
into the debate about well is that
really heavy metal or not i mean i'm
going to say they are
at least in in many respects and i i
think they're important in the formation
of american metal and you know you think
about
when did they come out 74 is their first
album
so they're really solidly in the middle
of that and then we have you know some
other bands that are that are you know
coming out with albums later on twisted
sisters a really great example
they're formed in new jersey originally
and hang out in long island
um they they play in clubs they bring d
snyder in
in 76 and then start moving towards a
heavier sound and they become metal
and but they don't actually bring out
their first album until i think
82 or so yeah yeah
another new york band that was really
important but unfortunately
got through you know no fault of their
own um
the win taken out of their sales was
riot if you if you've
never listened to rock city their 1977
album
that's really worth checking out they
followed it up with narita
and then um i'm blanking on the name of
it but it's got the song swords and
tequila which was anthologized
in a number of different things and they
were they were really solidly there
unfortunately when quiet riot became a
big thing
people confused the two and they quit
listening to riot but
riot was was so good that british uh
people were
saying these guys sound like the new
wave of british heavy metal let's
let's promote them here you know um
syrah ungl um a band that again you know
formed
in the early 70s they play a lot they
get heavier and heavier
sort of similar to twisted sisters uh
story their first album comes out in in
81 but they'd been doing metal
throughout the 70s and then we've got
you know the
la bands and so we can talk about van
halen formed in 74
quiet riot formed in 73.
you know there's connections between the
the la and
new york scenes because gene simmons
produced van halen's
first demos in 76 their first album
comes out in 78 and they take off from
there
quiet riot um had some hiccups at first
you know their their first two albums
are only released in japan they've never
been released in the states
and of course they you know when they
reform they they lose their
um guitarist to ozzy they break up for a
while get back together and then they
make it big
with with mental health in 82. there's
another
really important precursor band called
mickey rant
which includes for a little while jake
jakey lee
um and it's got steven percy in it
that's going to become
part of the rat story and then there's
another guy and
band who also includes some of the rat
people
and that's dawkin and we're going to
talk about him a bit more
later on um juan crocier of of rat
um plays in doc and at the same time as
he's
he's in rant so there's a lot of stuff
going on right
and all of this is identifiable as metal
and then we get into the bands where
here's where we're going to have a bit
more controversy
maybe it's metal maybe it's not so alice
cooper
tet nugent you know coming out of
detroit uh
ted nugent with the amboy dukes i think
some of that stuff
sounds pretty metal but maybe it really
is just hard rock and there's no
albums for either of them i think until
like the 80s where where heavy metal
becomes something identifiable where you
can say
like alice cooper is now doing metal um
he's making it a more metal sound i
think the the stuff in the 70s
is it metal i mean what do you think
scott and what what do you what do the
rest of you think
alice cooper and and ted nugent um
how should we describe them well alice
cooper you know i
i think well it's like kiss i don't
think kiss calls themselves heavy metal
right
they say we're a rock and roll band yeah
um and i think
um that's the same
um with like ted nugent
and then alice cooper i mean he had the
image although alice cooper was hanging
out with jimi hendrix
way back yeah and then that's right
i mean he's gonna he's gonna be a really
important influence on a lot of heavy
metal bands
including kiss well yeah but i'm going
to say yes
yeah you know like getting his head
chopped off and yeah
you know things that we would you know
like the saying oh that's so metal
you know um i think his antics were
always but like you know
oh yeah if you if you think about his
songs they sound like
i mean if if you showed somebody that
song these days it would sound like
classic rock
yeah um but even in the 80s when he did
stuff like poison
and um maybe some of that stuff was a
little more
aor but definitely like um you're right
as it goes on it becomes
heavier you know like as opposed to the
earlier stuff that was
very i mean everything was very classic
rock the riffs were pretty classic rock
yeah there's no more mr nice guy urshan
or anything like that either
i was listening to some of that stuff
the other day
uh because i wanted no i wanted to like
if i can corral somebody into being
metal i will so
yeah but you know it's funny because the
band he has now
um you know they're essentially
uh his band is essentially they're for
each of their fortes are or are
i would say heavy metal yeah
so you're saying he got heavy metal
musicians to come in and play with him
currently yeah currently it's like um
you know like nita strauss and you know
she's pretty much
just like a in a good way she's she's a
really good
heavy metal guitarist but um here's
here's
why i bring that up because i don't know
um if nita strauss
would want to go into say a rolling
stones type band
okay because that's a different style of
playing so the rolling stone is clearly
rock and roll
yeah um i think anything if she were to
cover those tunes
she would cover them in a metal style
like you know with the pitch harmonics
and the squealing and the
tapping and the super gain and it's not
a bad thing it's just
it's just her her taste it's it's her
style of playing
so if you think about who these people
surround themselves with
um alice cooper present day or the past
10 years
if you look at all their fortes are
pretty um
they would form their own metal band for
sure even when they play
now i haven't heard them play the old
stuff i would like to hear i should look
on youtube and hear alice cooper
like in 2017 playing the old stuff with
his new band and what it sounds like
yeah that's that's actually a great
index um
for for what it is now you know right i
mean we could we could say similar
things about
other people covering classic rock songs
as metal bands like you think about um
better by you better than me
when judas priest plays it it's a metal
song right absolutely when spooky tooth
played it originally it's
not um you know or
um wasp covering locomotive breath
now this is kind of a funny one since
jethro tull
actually won a gram he has a metal band
right you remember that whatever that
happened right
you know what but they're not they're
not a metal fan right um
because everybody was like appalled that
this took place
right and it becomes a or like when van
halen right
there a lot of their their early stuff
they have quite a few covers on it
um right you know girl you uh
uh uh you got me right yeah so the kinks
now proto metal but not metal van
covers it it's metal right i put them i
put the kinks more towards
punk okay that's just my thing i mean it
was great rock and roll but yeah
okay yeah yeah a little more towards
punk and their attitude and like um
um more towards like the clash okay
um but um as far as van halen like uh
well the pretty woman that didn't sound
like roy arbor said although it was the
same riff
yeah he played the same riff and it's
like the same part and it's like
you know david lee roth doing his thing
but um the band was definitely
like you know it wasn't light and rock
and roll it was it's got the elements
you can say the musical elements of
heavy metal the
heavy bass end you know the guitars are
pretty crunchy
well the guitar
so let's ask about a few other ones uh
aerosmith
metal non-metal what do you think i mean
some of the stuff you listen to it early
on is pretty heavy
and they definitely did try to like glom
on to the heavy metal thing in the 80s
um well are they metal or not no i mean
let's let's put anything they did in the
70s is
rock rock and roll i mean okay um
and then the 80s though that became like
diane warren started writing for them
now um tell us what that means because i
don't even
know how that would affect things so
diane warren's a very famous songwriter
um and i think it was starting on a
permanent vacation she wrote a lot of
the songs and then
you know like don't want to miss a thing
that
for the independence day she wrote that
and this is part of the reason stephen
tyler says we're not playing these songs
live
if you go see aerosmith they're not
going to play the diane warren songs
although that might not be entirely true
but you notice they got kind of
poppy and alr you know it was a little
more
i'm forgetting who produced but diane
warren wrote for everyone
and um once she moved in aerosmith i
don't know if they got heavier
i mean um toys in the attic was a
killer rock and roll record yeah i'm
trying to think in the 80s where it was
would be considered heavy metal
i think it's the stuff that we would
consider now we can call it
metal adjacent in the sense that like if
you listen to
these bands that were metal you probably
also listened to aerosmith in part
because they were playing
on some of the same stations right
there's a lot of overlap so like here in
milwaukee
we had wqfm which apparently was a real
hell hole to work in but it was like a
real powerhouse of a
music station and then we also had
um klh was was considered classic rock
but they would play some of the stuff
every once in a while the newer things
and then we had um i think it was andy
can correct me laser 103 came in
and um so we had like a couple different
stations that were
were doing some you know so they'd play
some metal songs like dio came out with
a new song okay you're going to hear it
there
the scorpions you know but you'll also
hear these other bands
and they they all would be part of you
know like one big playlist you could say
so you could you could easily associate
them even though they're not
you know so like think about train
captain roland right right is that a
metal song
well if you put it as i did when i was a
kid you know recording these things off
the radio on my tape recorder
right next to running with the devil
which followed it on that that
particular day
you might think that it's a metal sock
so uh mark says i agree cooper wasn't
really metal until the 80s not a fan of
nuget but
i'd say it gets close and that's it yeah
it gets kind of close
right um
andy says a tiny tangent but pre-screen
manilesia is so different than fleetwood
max oh
totally yeah it's hard it's hard to say
they're the same sound surprisingly
heavy for fleetwood mac
whereas diamonds and rust is so much
more emotional for me when done by
priest because of halford's voice being
so much more yearning than joan baez
interesting too because joan baez had
more verses right so
there's more lyrical quality there
there's more quantity
she can you know sketch out the the
scenario but i think you're right
halford's voice
even though they took out some of the
verses that where he could have added
even more emotional stuff
it it's all you need for that one uh she
also writes now nirvana is on the mke
easy listening station
yeah we we what did that happen
i remember nirvana like i still consider
them a new band
just because of my age if they came in
and you know when them and pearl jam in
the seattle the seattle scene
yeah well we all know seattle is queen's
right but
yeah but um when they came in well you
know
they named it grunge immediately and i
would just not to go off topic but as
as far as we're labeling things
uh immediately calling this grunge and
then
for those of you that don't play guitar
they used to like all the
pedal companies would make a grunge
pedal which was just basically a
distortion pedal maybe yeah
distorted but they named it grunge but
really
people just went back to playing the
instruments that people were using in
the 70s
and um getting rid of the pointy head
stock flying v
guitars getting rid of you know all that
so it's like um but that's an mtv thing
mtv
actually coined the name hair bands
which
isn't really fair you know um because
some musicians are bald or balding
well they don't hear that but i mean you
know the the reason they called it hair
band was to make fun of it so they could
bring in their new
right i mean look let's face it grunge
was hair band too it was
okay we're not gonna do our hair up
we're not gonna we're all gonna wear
flannel
we're all gonna wear the same thing
we're not gonna shower for days and
that's gonna be the new cool
so it was the new image is oh
everything's reactionary in music
when you when you look at musically
grunge
and 80s heavy metal there's so much
overlap
and even some of the um traits that
they'll use to differentiate them oh you
know they didn't do guitar solos and
grunge
that's totally false i mean think about
some of like pearl jam's uh
you know alive song right there's
there's a a
great guitar solo on that um and and i
i think a lot of the the air
that was you know sort of the ballast uh
i'm gonna mix a lot of metaphors here
but you know
for for metal bands in like from 89
onward
into the early 90s got sucked into
grunge
and now they were you like you're saying
they they dress different that's true
some of the lyrical content might have
been a bit different
um there were some you know bands that
were kind of crossover like is alice in
chains metal or grunge
i i was so that's the or sound garden
yeah yeah
um but just to go with the guitar solo
here's the big difference
the voca um i i've yet to ever hear a
solo done in the 90s in the grunge era
that that's vocabulary reached past
1975.
so the alive solo the alive solo is just
a bunch of
licks you would have heard in 19 well
taking out van halen yeah but it would
it was kind of like hendrixy kind of
licks
maybe almond brothers he kind of licks
but we they took out the tapping they
took
out the sweeping they took out um so the
vocabulary all the guitarists used were
you know uh many decades before
and i think if that guitarist got up
there and started to play like a
legato i mean like one of those fast
yeah you know lines um
the producer would have said nope and so
i don't think grunge was anything new
grunge was going back to
uh rock and roll or they were trying to
go back to rocket on the vocabulary the
songwriting
uh some of the clever um
[Music]
uh chordal devices they would expand to
in the 80s
they they said no more we're going back
to
you know so it was it was the grunge was
nothing new except for the the image
to me and i'm not putting it down
because allison change is great
um sound garden um unbelievable love
those bands
i'm just laughing because i'm looking at
a comment from mark
uh who who i know is younger than us
somebody told me slipknot
is old-school metal and man it made me
feel old yeah there's there's this whole
like
generational churn isn't there i have a
i had a student
the other day say that exactly same
thing i said you know that slipknot is
is uh old-school metal interesting
she said i'm into old school metal and
i'm like
thinking to myself great we gotta talk
to briefly before i could get a word out
she's like you know like slipknot
and i was like old school heavy you know
remember when we were in high school we
keep talking about like rock and roll is
only around
15 20 years and metal was you know
around very less yeah even less
and um now it's kind of like you hear
people say
i love classic rock like nirvana
and i don't know what to make of that
you know i guess
what is it like vintage is like they
consider 25 years as vintage
okay it is kind of the benchmark for
like guitar gear for like
if you could go on the classic rock
station it's not gonna be something in
the last ten years
yeah i mean if we if we date uh the
inception of heavy metal to
1970 which i think is reasonable so now
it's 50 years
right um
25 years would take us to 1995.
yeah at that time a lot of the what we
consider classic metal bands had had
broken up they were in their very lean
years if they were surviving
it was usually by like touring in japan
and europe and and you know
they they weren't they weren't getting a
lot of traction um
i think you know soon after that we
start to see the the big festivals
happening and that that provides them
with an opportunity to see all these
bands getting back together
around like 2000 or so um
and who who are the people i mean
there's a total digression but who was
who were the
the bands that we would consider like
current metal
in 95 tool um alice in chains
helmets you know all these these bands
that really
hadn't been around that that long at
that time right
so yeah every tool
that's an interesting one because you
know is depeche mode heavy metal
oh i would say no because it's mostly
synth right
well here's right but here's what the
total is tool is a lot of electronic so
here's where that you you you opened
with this kind of idea yeah
so depeche mode got heavier in the 90s
and um but tool is
i would call them post to pesh mode
there would be no tool without depeche
mode
interesting so so when we talk about
like
is like blue oyster cult you mentioned
earlier yeah
karma says no we we weren't into that we
came from
the hate ashbury scene he was very much
they were
very much well let's let's let's shift
to that topic because i
was definitely what i wanted to talk
about um
so here's here's the challenges right
they got called
the thinking man's heavy metal and you
listen to some of the songs like
godzilla is definitely a metal song you
know
and they their their stuff appeared
in the movie heavy metal right now
granted
the the some of the stuff on heavy metal
like sammy hagar's heavy metal
wasn't heavy metal you know he's got a
song called heavy metal
on in the soundtrack for the movie heavy
metal and it's it's just hard rock you
know
right but i think i think some of the
oyster called stuff can be said to be
heavy metal even if the even if the
origin was different
and even if bakdharma doesn't want to
call it heavy metal and say it's
something different
i think in a very broad sense shouldn't
we shouldn't we still call it heavy
metal now i know you think that
they shouldn't so well i think they well
i think they should so i think
thinking about this there's a few things
to me that make them heavy battle
the rifts are heavy but the rifts are
clever and you don't expect them
if i can demonstrate um
i hope you don't mind no absolutely
so here's here's seven screaming dizz
busters
that chord you don't expect it's yeah
out of um and then like hot rails to
hell and all that and
um well yeah uh
i mean how's that not heavy metal
[Music]
yeah and mark mark says cities on flame
is definitely heavy metal
uh you don't get crunch and rock i think
what
so buck all he says is
i mean i guess heavy metal didn't really
exist when he was starting
i mean it didn't exist as
yeah definitely didn't exist back then
but in the band coming together
there's there's talk of heavy metal but
nobody nobody's quite sure what it means
sometimes it's just a derogatory way of
putting down this heavy stoner rock you
know
yeah so he so he'll say we came from the
haiti ashbury people like jefferson
airplane we came from the psychedelic
rock but
you also say to him you guys are the
first to do this or you were to do this
and he goes yeah we were the first to do
a lot of things
but maybe i i you know i think
he wasn't saying that pretentiously he's
yeah joking with himself
like we did a lot of bad stuff too
but i think i think if i were to
if you're to say hey bucks did you did
people
all the metalheads copy you he would say
you know you know probably but um
you know that even that first album that
came out in 71
it's pretty heavy i mean yeah and um
and you know yeah city's on flame um
well of course godzilla but dominant
submission
i mean there's no way um
we wouldn't call it heavy metal but i
think
i think he's just saying look heavy
metal didn't influence us we just
came from haight ashbury and then this
is the sound we came up with
but i think it's not only the heaviness
it's that that weird
that's why they called the thinking
man's heavy metal like why are we in
this section suddenly
why are we in this and they're some of
them are kind of complicated riffs
when i was young i was going where would
you find that in the scale
well it's not really scale it just
sounded good to them
that's an interesting uh issue that you
bring up about like
influence um some of the bands that we
talked about
earlier like um for example bang you
know they they said we're
we're influenced by black sabbath we're
trying to do something similar to what
they're doing same
i think you can say something similar
with pentagram right yeah
maybe that whole um proto
doom metal scene you can say well
there's a really strong
clear line of influence and with others
it's harder to
to say you know and it's kind of weird
too like you look at um
so earlier before we got started we were
talking about steve harris
who does steve harris uh the basis for
iron maiden
credit you know he talks about ufo
oh yeah absolutely and he doesn't talk
so much about say what geezer butler's
doing or
you know what roger glover's doing and
and and then when you ask
like uh bruce dickinson is in his
biography oh you know who are the people
that you look up to
for him it was definitely he was less
interested in black sabbath and he was
much more interested
in uh deep purple and and ian gillen
and gillen was like his idol he talks
about getting to meet him at one time
when he was in
samson so i think there's like a broad
distribution of like we're influenced by
these
and so if you're influenced by bands
that are identifiable as metal well
you're probably going to be more
you know identifiable as metal whereas
if you are blue easter cult and you're
coming out of this other
this other scene um it kind of makes
sense why you would say no no we're not
we're not doing what those guys are
doing you know
um yeah and go back to like the lyrics
um the first album um
there's a song called last days of may
on the first album buck dahmer wrote it
he sings it it's a slow song
but it's the first song of its type that
i know that talks about
you know like the summer of love being
69 drugs are great free love
and the song that buck dahmer wrote was
about
not glorifying and saying look people
died
look you know it's a story about so he's
continuing on what was the big festival
that the stones hired this
the hell's angels oh right in 1970 and
it was awful like you know um so
but vloister colt's content is you know
post you know summer of love just you
know he wrote it
probably in 70. but they sing about
sci-fi they're sci-fi freaks yeah
yeah and um you know i don't know half
of the stuff they're singing about but
apparently i mean
you know it's it's it's legitimate it
sounds cool
yeah i mean you know extraterrestrial
intelligence and
you know bti all that stuff so what do
you think about
mark has another one he says i'd call
astronomy
the song astronomy metal the way it's
structured i draw a line from a song
like that to something like metallica's
sanitarium
um what i mean what do you think do you
see that there
it's funny you say that mark because um
uh metallica is um
is obsessed with bloister cult you
always see them with blister called
t-shirts they actually caught
um covered astronomy on their garage one
of their garage days albums
and there's a story of them um of who
of lars um joe bouchard the bass player
for boys occult not anymore
he said he was like at a metallica show
and lars chased after him and said i
want your autograph i want a picture
with you
which is interesting so that's a you
know astronomy
is it metal i mean it's kind of a slow
song
and then it kind of you know gets into
this rock and roll thing but the lyrics
yeah i mean i guess if sanitarium that's
i don't know that's a good point but
there is a connection between the two
bands
and so they can nail that lars ulrich is
kind of an interesting character in this
uh this respect as well because he was
he was like involved with with fan clubs
he was the president of the motorhead
fan club
and oh i didn't even know that yeah and
and you know so he's he was the
connection between
metallica as a band uh it's not like the
other guys weren't listening to stuff
right
and cliff burton clearly i mean
listening to all sorts of
cool stuff who knows what would have
happened with metallica he'd not died
um good point but but lars was the one
who has tapped into this
vast metal community and would write the
letters to people
you know like writing to lemmy as a
president of the fan club right
and listening to all this um
all this you know more obscure like
bands that never managed to like punch
their way up into the top tier
and saying this is really cool stuff we
should we should cover this we should
listen to this we should do this you
know
um so i think i think there's probably a
very interesting story to be told
about about him and his role as kind of
like a nexus
and this is actually a good place to
jump off although we'll come back to
kiss we'll come back to
a few other bands that we want to talk
about are they really metal or not
but you know in the 1980s there's this
creative eruption that's
primed to happen and that's you know
what we have is like the la
um glam slash hair slash whatever you
want to call it
scene that that you know had quiet riot
and
and van halen and mickey rat are kind of
preparing the way for
there's that going on there's also you
know
the new wave of british heavy metal in
in england
and you know other places there's some
cool stuff happening in
europe and in japan you know
traditional power or heavy you know
whatever we want to call it
uh metal is is also going to do a lot of
stuff in the 80s and then we have thrash
and all of this is getting getting
primed in in some respect by what's
happening
in the states um and so some of this is
developing through like tours
tours i think were massively important
um
you know you support other bands you
headline you travel around you
introduce your sound to people so you
know if you're not in
you know we've talked about like new
york city and la as being really
important places for the us
and detroit to to a lesser extent but if
you're out in the sticks and and
some cool bands come by you could like
be inspired well we should form a band
ourself right and that's part of what
what happens
um the local bar and club scenes that
played an important role allows bands to
come
up but notice this is all urban right
it's it's
you have to have access to something
like that and then we've got you know
things that can reach other people
the record companies for better for
worse and their distribution
um you know radio play was a big
issue uh tv you know eventually mtv is
going to be really important and then
later vh1 but you know there's other
ways to get
on tv and the magazines that we used to
buy in the drugstores like circus
which was not originally about heavy
metal you know it was about other stuff
but it shifted
as they realized there was money to be
made
parader right i mean operator yeah
that's right
unless you lived in a really big urban
setting you probably weren't getting the
british metal
scenes right like karang you know um
like i know you i don't think you could
have found that anywhere around this
area
except maybe in a specialty shop at that
time
but there's there's a couple other
things that are really important i think
and one of these is on sort of a higher
level
it has to do with the musicians like
who's who's producing who's promoting
and managing
ronnie james dio is a great example of
this
i mentioned gene simmons helping to
produce van halen's original demo
there were people like that who and it
was especially associated with that like
la to new york nexus who are like well
this band is good we got to do something
with them
we're going to we know a little bit more
about how the business works
you know we're a bit more veterans
although not that much more
let's help them out prime example of
this ronnie james dio
and wendy dia with the band rough cut
that jk lee was
in before he transitioned over to
playing with with ozzie
after he left mickey rat they took a
real
interest in that there were all these
bands that were being promoted like that
and then the other thing that i think
really played a major role
that some of us participated in was that
tape sharing thing
you know you could you could get your
sound out there
um not just by recording an ep but you
could actually have a demo
that people would would dub and
you know the technology got better and
better and better i think many of us
remember when
when tapes um you know like they they
started having higher quality
cassette tapes right it would be more
fidelity
it wouldn't break down as quickly and
you'd have to get in there and like get
it out of your tape player
there are all sorts of stories that can
be told about that but
you know what we know is that these tape
sharing
communities which would sometimes be
advertised in the metal scenes
um played an incredibly important role
in getting
like sounds circulated if you didn't
live in a big urban area
like new york city or that whole nexus
of
new jersey and long island with it or
la or san diego or any of these places
so that you know i think that played a
major
role all these different overlapping
things in getting this
almost like powder keg ready to to
explode
yeah the tape sharing is fascinating um
and that you know
of course the attitudes are very
different now about you know
file sharing or streaming this is this
is a different era but back then
um you know what like you know but back
then you know
a friend would um give you a mixtape of
like the
you know all you got to hear like these
pre-songs and these maidens
and what happened you wanted your own
copy so it also led to even like
independent like you know eps or
whatever you'd go around until you found
it so you can have your own copy of it
um but yeah it was a way if you weren't
in like
new york city um that you would hear
these new sounds
that you would hear uh and then um then
you
what did you do you went to the record
store and you got into it and remember
buying albums um that i've never heard
before it's like so-and-so has a new
record well i'm gonna buy it
and i'll get home and maybe i'll be
disappointed but
um mark has a really interesting thing
that he said here when i was in high
school is flash stick
trading or cell phone bluetooth swap so
i mean same sort of
yeah same sort of basic idea different
medium and i was going to say you know
there were all these labels that came on
tapes
when we were in high school or they'd be
like the fbi is going to come down on
you if you copy this you know
and nobody cared right because the fbi
is not investigating little fish like us
who are you know buying the latest [ __ ]
or wasp
uh like you know the last command right
and then putting it into our um
boom box that has the two tape things
and hitting record
they're not gonna care about that you
know or there'd be like somebody who'd
buy an
album and um they would make a copy
on tape so that they didn't have to play
their album
and then they'd like play it somewhere
and you'd be like oh that's cool man
can i get a copy of that then you'd copy
his tape and you know by by the time
that you're like three tapes in
the sound quality is terrible you know
it's not like mp3s
right well mp3s are pretty bad i mean
mp3s
are are cassette tapes are
widely uh wildly better fidelity than
mp3
really oh yeah mp3s are um but not not
like the stuff that we'd record
you know several copies of a copy right
down the line
mp3s are its own thing like if you turn
off tape at least it gets fatter
okay um or vinyl if you crank vinyl the
louder you get the fuller and warmer it
gets
people are damaging their hearings with
mp3s because
it's very it's it's low it's so you can
fit a lot into small things
um interesting you said so oh you know
but you know what the solution to the
copying tape thing was i don't know if
any of you remember this or
or realized it but in around 94
the government decided to impose a blank
tape tax
so um when you bought black tapes you
paid
a few dollars extra for them and their
solution was it's going to go to
whoever's in the top 10.
so our argument was we had those uh
four-track tape recorders where we
record our own music
and i'm saying so you're telling me that
i'm recording my own music as as a 19
year old in my basement and i have to
pay madonna
and you know that was their solution
it's like you know
legally i don't know how that got
through because i i thought the law said
if
if it had other uses you couldn't do
that you know it's okay
but so any anyways that became even with
the two inch tapes that people the
master tapes that bands would go into
studios and record on before it was
mixed
those were and what they said is well
you're probably copying whoever's in the
top
20. so what we're going to do is that
money's going to go to those record
companies
so the tape tag never really actually
really went to the artist that went to
the
companies right yeah i think it went to
the companies but the ones that
um it went to the companies that and
they would have to
share the money with the top 20 whatever
their deal was whoever owned
publishing or the songwriting so let's
say
to make it easy it would be 50 50. so if
a hundred dollars got sent
to capitol records they'd give 50 bucks
to
the artists and they'd keep 50 or or or
divide it up
in that way so that was a it was a
terrible solution i remember when it
came out it was like
now it's costing me more to put out now
like let's say
i'm making my own tape you know and i'm
i'm
i want to give a few out to friends i
have to pay capital records for it
so that was uh yeah that was a bad
solution uh that
you know i they were trying to stop but
you know
now that that seems so silly because
now nobody's making money nobody's
really selling albums that's gone
this goes to mark's comment sounds like
spotify
i know you have some strong feelings
about that well i do spotify
just to put it clearly they say they
have a product but they don't they're a
platform
it's like if i own a starbucks
and i don't have coffee nobody's coming
into the store
so just a quick thing about spotify just
by my own soapbox
um you don't have to when people
complain about spotify
i don't have my stuff on spotify i sell
it right for my site so
anybody that's complaining about spotify
well you have the power to pull your
stuff off
we actually have the power if we all
pulled our music off
spotify would go bankrupt so
i don't know i have mixed feelings about
it but like i'm gonna say something too
about spotify so
i i don't produce music but i produce
podcasts
and you know i'm on soundcloud that's
that's the main thing for sadler's
lectures and then it goes out
immediately to apple music
and to google whatever google's thing is
and to amazon and all these different
platforms and
every once in a while i find out that
there's like a platform out there
that's already just sucking stuff from
soundcloud onto that
every time that i post like i posted a
video about the the podcast recently
and the first couple comments were
well you need to have this on on spotify
uh because that's where everybody is
and i was like you have like 30
different places where you can find this
you know every one of them is available
to you as an app
why the hell and the problem is of
course soundcloud and spotify don't play
well together you know so otherwise
i'd probably do it um because i i'm not
making money on it you know if
i was if it was exclusive i probably
would but i'm like why are you so
beholden to this one single platform
that's that's the only place you think
you can get something that you are
demanding
that content producers put put it on
there you know that's how lazy
yeah i'm the littlest of little fish you
know but i'm sure there that that other
artists who
aren't on spotify are getting like
hammered on this
you know by like you said people who are
kind of lazy and don't want to
like do two more clicks to get the stuff
you know
i'll never forget the first time i got a
text years ago
i i whatever came first i put out
i put out an album that just came out i
was advertising it
and i got texts from people actually
saying
do you have maybe soundcloud and i said
no
they said well i can't really afford
your album i go
since when can't you afford the 10 bucks
like what is that a big deal
i know you buy like three eight dollar
lattes
in a day i don't know so it's it's the
casualty it's it's um
with the music the major the major
labels are getting
paid by spotify but i say 90
of anybody that has their stuff on well
they're just profiting
off of you and yeah now with artists
they're just happy with brag
i got a hundred thousand listens we got
two dollars
and um so i i actually i
blame i don't blame spotify they can do
whatever they want they can actually
they people do
pay to get recognized more so they're
paying spotify
to have their stuff harvested wow
and so that's that's that's on us that's
on the musicians you know what
because spotify can say we will take
your firstborn and if you give them your
firstborn
there's there's no harm in them asking
you to do it
it's not the only game in town yeah you
said
and you could by the way anybody in the
technology these days you can set up
everything you want on your website
people can visit your website and enjoy
the content
um or or pay for it or you know
um so i don't i i don't
people always understand you need to
change with the times man and every
single one of those people
have day jobs i don't so
there's something to be said it's like
change with the times well what's the is
this a means to an end
yeah yeah but here's where metal fans
this here's where
metal bands do pretty well metal fans if
we all know
treat their fans well so maybe it's 15
bucks but it
comes with two cds a blu-ray uh you know
it comes
in and maybe guitar picks and swag yeah
so and and the fans are like we want to
pay for this
so i feel like metal like doro i saw
dora a few years ago
and she was selling hard copies from her
you know
stuff was flying from her merch booth
cds and
um i just feel like there's something
about that
not to jump all the way back but that no
no i i think that's right i mean every
major concert that we've gone to
recently with the exception of the
concerts that are
at um the local casino the potawatomi
where they don't have the space to do
this there's a merch booth
and the lines are long to like when we
saw judas priest you know i want to get
um a shirt for for me and a shirt for
for andy's mom uh and um
you know is it during an intermission
between the opening band and judas
priest i probably waited in line like
you know
10 minutes to get up to the front of the
line because people will buy the merch
and that's that's where
i mean we could have a whole
conversation about how do people eat in
in in music because it's changed
radically over time
you know it used to be that album sales
were what we're gonna really propel you
now it's
touring and selling merch that's the
main way to do it
um and so loyalty like you were saying
is is really fundamental in that
and that's a two-way street this goes
back to like when we had our
our uh conversation a couple times back
about the ethics of doing
farewell tours and then not ending it
and then going on another farewell tour
and how it's kind of like a breach of
loyalty with the fans you know if you do
stuff like that
um that may actually have a rightfully
an impact on whether people are going to
buy your merch
you know well you had a great you had a
great quote by it still rains with me i
love the quote you read from d
snyder saying thanks a lot ozzy you know
i paid top dollar for the ticket yeah i
also bought it
right i also bought all the like you
know final tour merch
because this was it i was gonna have
something worth value to me
um and that was the no more tours that
was like 92 90
yeah um but it's true i do think there's
a loyalty with metal
so um and actually country music
apparently sells a lot of albums like
taylor swift still still sells physical
albums
um but the metal fans they will buy
the cds you know it was a good idea does
anybody remember
maybe 10 15 years ago every time you
went to a concert you could pay
20 bucks and you would receive that
night's concert
on cd does no i used to do that
that's interesting so like you would go
to the merch booth and you would
give like 20 bucks and they you'd fill
out this thing and then like
a month later the show you went to would
show up with
usually a two cd set from the sound
board what a great idea
i don't know if they're doing that
anymore but you're selling albums then
and
you're part of say you're in a pre-show
and it's the show that you were at you
get the live show from there yeah
listen to for the rest of your life yeah
i don't i i i've never actually seen
that andy says it's like the best
possible bootleg
because it's not some crappy sound
quality from some guy bringing in a
recorder
and peter gabriel did that like you
could go to his website you could buy
any show
oh interesting um but yeah it's it's
best possible bootleg
and you don't mind paying for it um
i don't mind you know yeah me but like
that's not something that's going to be
on spotify in other words
it's something unique that's you know um
which they've done that for a pre-show
at riverside with a 10-minute range oh i
know
we'll see maybe that's something when
this comes back to be discussed because
you need to bring people people need to
people don't value music that's the
harsh byproduct of
technology is well this just got no
monetary value i don't want to pay for
that
but you know if you're part of something
like a show
i'd probably pay for it metal metal
artists like it's
it's a two-way street you've been there
for me i want to buy your newest t-shirt
your newest coffee mug
and they'll usually have their albums
there it's like oh it's a deluxe edition
i want to buy this one
yeah um it's probably and that's you
know we go back to the beginning of this
conversation where it's
there's a connection you started saying
they're um
you know the the critics hated them that
the radio wouldn't play metal
um the underdog yeah the underdog
and i think the underdogs of
the people that feel alone in some ways
they're
either uh agoraphobic or they're
shy or and but they can put the
headphones on and get that emotion
and feel the the power of the music and
the lyrics as you've said and um
that's i think that's a big deal with
heavy metal i've always seen that
and i i identify although i love so many
styles of music but
you know sometimes i'll get my head
space and i'll put the headphone lights
out just telling greg
before he started i was cranking that uh
accept live album from 1985
stay in a life and man they sounded
great and it was just a whole
head trip for me that i just i really
enjoyed it it was just kind of like
yeah let's let's come back to
um one of the key questions that we were
gonna talk about like who is metal and
who's
who's not so um
i had a few other ones lined up but i
think i just wanna only only
pick two um one of them is ramjam
we've all heard black betty right and
ram jam actually only they produced like
two albums
um they definitely were not ready for
the mtv look because they
they are crazy looking you know they
they didn't have the photogenic sort of
thing
if you've ever like looked at the video
for for black betty
um is black betty metal or
is it is it just hard rock let me ask
you this is fleetwood max oh well heavy
metal
okay so it's kind of the same thing it's
kind of like
it's got a heavy guitar riff and then
you know it's about like you know
you think i'm ugly but don't ask me what
i think of you and
i mean we could we could we could um say
and it's interesting because when you
look at like
metal anthologies or listings and stuff
from the early 80s we could also talk
about queen
is queen metal i would say no definitely
not but
you know um and some people made an
argument that they should be included in
there or you know another
another one that's kind of funny is
slade slate isn't metal
but people want to say that they were
back in the 70s you know
well queen for their presentation i mean
what's more epic than flash gordon i
mean it's
over the top it's it's you know i think
for as far as theatrics you know yeah
you know riding on darth vader's
shoulders uh during shows i think
that's like the alice cooper thing it's
kind of like well it's got the whole
theatrical aspect to it yeah
arrangements but yeah as far as
i think queen's their own thing it's
it's remarkable what they did but i
i would agree like you know um they had
heavy songs but
i don't know what to call them slaves
yeah i agree mark yeah and i think there
was
like you mentioned the new york dolls
earlier right yeah
they were glam rock they weren't heavy
metal right they
there was a genre of glam rock that
could be heavy
but could also be you know more soft as
well
i think really in order to be glam rock
it just had to be very glammy
right you know like a lot of the punk
bands were kind of glam in their own way
um or perceive themselves um who am i
thinking of
um like iggy pop
yeah or like you know look at david
bowie i mean
talk about pediatrics it's interesting
that you bring up punk because
so we'll come back to some of the the
topics i was going to like slide
out on a bit more but so in the 1970s
both punk and heavy metal
kind of competed for some of the same
space
there was some overlap and i remember
when i was
in high school um the older kids
like in the very early 80s there were a
lot of
at least here in wisconsin there was a
lot of acrimony between heavy metal
people and punk people
like they would beat each other up and
you know punk as junk
heavy metal socks you know and and you
know it was
maybe is because there was too much in
common with them so there was that going
on which was kind of interesting
and there's a really great book i don't
remember the author but it's called this
ain't the summer of love which is
specifically about
that phenomenon of the punk versus metal
oh rivalries in the 70s and 80s
but i think there's also something so
i'll bring up just one example of a
person algae ward right
lg ward was in the damned the damned is
a punk band
they're not metal he comes out of that
and
forms tank which is definitely metal but
definitely
you know punk infused as a matter of
fact some people are saying they're a
motorhead kind of clone right
uh but they they did their own thing by
the
mid by the mid 80s they've got two
guitarists
they're they've got a much heavier sound
with honor and blood
and that's sort of like the tank going
forward the earlier stuff is really
great um like run like hell for example
which was anthologized on quite a few
heavy metal you know like a metal
killer's collection for example
um and um you know so you do have like
some
metal we've talked about paul diano too
paul diana was essentially a punk
singer which is why he wasn't that he's
he he's good in
in iron maiden but iron maiden couldn't
realize their full potential
with him as their singer he also did a
lot of drugs and got drunk all the time
and it was kind of unpredictable so they
gave him the boot and then they bring in
something
by definition true yeah yeah
yeah but they bring in somebody who's
definitely an established metal singer
because because bruce dickinson wasn't
just like off the street he'd been
in samson he did two albums with them
you know
so i think there's there's um you could
say that the heavy metal scene is
is drawing on some some punk people and
you know sucking them in
you know um later on in the 80s you know
there's questions like well is black
flag punk or can we call them metal
you know um they'd appear in the metal
magazines i remember seeing
ads for their stuff there you know i
mean i wouldn't consider that metal but
i think some people did
no i would never know i know i did um
in fact anything that um henley henry
rollins ever spoke about
or the the classic you know
like the stooges like yeah um
you know henry rowland's you know of
course he's he's kind of a musicologist
himself he's
he loves but he's he's
yeah he's he's he's punk that album that
he did in the 90s though that had lyre
on it
and stuff like that that's that's a
pretty metal album you know
i don't know if i've actually heard that
one yeah i'll check it out
interestingly that's one that i that got
onto my radar because at that time i was
working a
security job and um
you know i was working late night so
like mtv would be on and i'd
zone out and smoke a cigarette while i'm
on a break and watch mtv and then
that song was on mark mark also points
out stormtroopers of death
yeah that's that's a great example sod
right
flows into anthrax um those those are
some good examples
so let's come back to the question of
who's who's who's actually
metal what what characteristics do you
have to have
in order to be metal and let's use kiss
as an example
i'm willing to say that kiss is metal
although
you know like the solo albums maybe not
so much
right oh yeah and definitely some songs
like beth is not metal
and there's no way you can you can twist
that to make it metal but you know uh
king of the nighttime world
um shock me um colgin i would say
those are metal songs you know um what
do you think
or do you want to say that they're
they're hard rock they're not they're
kind of veering towards it but they're
not really
metal what's your i think i okay so
something that we've been talking about
here like with kiss with queen with
alice cooper is
there are things that might be metal
about him for example to go back to
queen
maybe it's because it's so epic and
theatrical musically
yeah maybe because alice cooper was you
know having his head chopped off and
in the go you know um yeah for kiss
well they had this you know comic book
character look
uh they had the theatrics yeah um but
like you know
a lot of those riffs were like um
like called gin and all that those are
keith richards riffs you know
all the and what i mean by that is like
that
you know it's like um
[Music]
yeah yeah so a lot of the kiss tunes
were
basically like keith richards riffs but
heavier
with you know um oh what's the one
right uh
uh what's onto my tongue the kiss tune
why would i forget this i'm a big kiss
fan
but it's it's got the guitar riffs are
kind of rock and roll
and the solos are i love ace freely
yeah his fan you know what nobody could
replace him he had his own way
but he's a rock and roll guitar player
um
but i don't know i you know another
thing that's kind of interesting about
kiss as a band
when you think about it is they
effectively have
three singers right there are songs
where
and now paul stanley is more
the lead singer but there's a lot of
gene simmons songs and there's
quite a few a street league songs peter
chris not so much
um but having more than one person
doing vocals um usually in most metal
bands
it's it's either like there's one main
person or like with rat
for example um you don't really you
don't really have rat without both steve
and percy and juan croach here because
what juan is doing he gets credited as a
what is it not lead vocalist uh the
backup vocals but
he's really part of the sound for for
the lyrics
and you can really hear that when you
listen to them in concert these days
because stephen percy can't sing as high
anymore
yeah you know um god the kiss is a tough
one
i think they have elements of metal what
do you think about
mark's uh suggestion they're a hard rock
band with
heavy metal songs and maybe we'd say
like some albums there's more of them
and maybe like some periods like in the
early 80s
maybe they're more metal than they were
i mean i still want to say they're a 70s
metal band myself because and maybe it's
a matter of the influence so many people
talk about
kiss you know listening to kiss
among younger bands that you know are
showing up in the
80s and 90s that kiss
influenced them but they don't always
say exactly how they influence them so
maybe maybe there's something to be said
you know maybe it is the theatricality
um
well if you think about songs like king
of the mountain
that's quite a metal tune um or even you
go to crazy nights and fight hell to
whole you hold you
i don't know if every anybody had that
album crazy nights but fight hell to
hold you
um that's a pretty metal tune
i mean um not so much on
i i guess there's certain stuff i guess
that after vinnie vincent left for a few
years
they had stuff that i would say this is
or they definitely stepped into aor
yeah um which we we may or may not
consider that metal like
melodic with hard guitars but paul
stanley definitely had the
the vocal chops back in the day yeah
uh death covered god of thunder no i
didn't hear that
god of thunder i think it's a metal song
you know
uh yeah i mean i'm gonna say something
too that i was telling andy about the
other day
when it was valentine's day my mom was
kind of a quirky character
and for valentine's day she would often
you know she'd like buy us the candy and
stuff like that and then be around the
house
but she'd often buy us albums and it'd
be like who are we into
and she bought me a kiss destroyer and
like a valentine's day day present and
you know i went up and
obviously we were like totally into kiss
when i was a kid we would like get our
crayons
and you know make our our own little you
know like kiss
emblems that we'd cut out of paper and
then like pin to our clothes with
clothes pins
and we would draw the characters doing
things you know
uh i was big on ace freely of course as
a spaceman
and um yeah so as soon as i had the
record i like went up to my room
on my little crappy um phonograph and
started listening to
it yeah
yeah i have a friend i must have been in
fourth grade
he he just got a copy of kiss alive too
we had the fisher price
yeah that's what i had yeah and
he goes you gotta hear this and he put
on love gun
yeah and i was like whoa see i went over
to
there there were these two guys who were
a year older than me jeff and jay
and these guys were like freaking frack
they were real rum-dums they were always
getting in trouble
you know they were the kids that got
into drugs in high school stuff like
that
and they were in my neighborhood and and
they had
um kiss jeff van meter had kiss alive
too and so we would go to his place he
also had a couple other kiss things and
we would listen to it you know like
played cranked up as loud as
as it could be and then we'd come back
to my place and that's when we do the
crayon drawings
stuff like that awesome oh yeah i used
to do that
like the kiss of blue circle i used to
make my own
i used to stick frames that my mom
wasn't using and try to make a
you know i remember tracing the the
album cover or something yeah
um but there we go there's the
connection there's the
i don't know if people were doing that
to madonna albums or
um duran duran albums although i love
those band i love derandori
i'm not saying but i'm just saying the
the kind of dedication or the connection
that we had that
we wanted to be part of this world
somehow even if we have to like make the
characters
into actual characters like you were
saying
like yeah ace really had the guitar that
shot you know
you know like how cool is that yeah
when we saw him in concert recently he
had uh he still
he wasn't shooting out the the neck it
was like
something coming out the the back of the
guitar um
which you know seems a little risky
but he seems like the kind of guy who
likes to take risks yeah
so i i did say we wanted to talk about
um
another another band which is dakin and
doc and you might say well they formed
in 1979 so they're a little bit late in
this
this story but dawkin was doing stuff
dondak and in la
before that and he was in a band called
airborne
and he had um bobby blotzer and juan
crocier of rat
later rat in that band at the same time
they left for another
band eventually but crochet came back
and then
um he toured germany in 79 80 and 81
and there he met this guy michael wagner
who is the sound engineer for accept but
also was doing producing as well
and he demoed some songs for the
scorpions because some of you
you know may remember there was a time
when klaus mine had
it was questionable whether he'd
actually be able to sing again he had he
had
vocal chord problems kind of similar to
what ian gillen went through
and so don docken was singing for
for the scorpions at that time um
and so he's in some respects part of the
la scene but also a connection
to to the german scene that's going on
in the 70s and early 80s and i think
there's a lot of these interconnections
between you know what's happening
particularly in new york and la but also
in other places by the time we get to
like 1980
and also what's happening in britain
which is now exploding
around that time into the new wave of
british heavy metal already has this
well-established
metal um you know you could call it
musical
soundscape and also fan base
but then you've got you know europe
which is primarily at that time you know
the germans but also the scandinavians
are getting into it there's some french
bands as well
and then then japan and i think a lot of
this is
is uh kind of connected together the
other thing i did want to bring up as
well
is that that english connection and this
is something scott and i have talked
about
it kind of you know part of it is kind
of like poaching on the la
scene so ozzy is a prime example of this
you know quiet riot
um was already having trouble because
kevin dubrow couldn't get along with
anybody
and randy rhodes was you know he wasn't
happy with that
and so when when ozzy offers him a gig
um he jumps ship and quiet riot falls
apart you know
and um jakey lee gets gets you know i'll
just call it poached by
by ozzy uh shortly after that when randy
rhodes dies
um and there's there's a lot of this uh
stuff and it's happening
in significant part because of these uh
venues like the rainbow
you know musicians come through they
play in la they hang out at the rainbow
they meet the young up-and-coming stars
they suck them in the english bands will
often have
these other uh bands playing with them
opening for them
you know older example black sabbath had
kiss opening for them
there's another tour where i think black
sabbath may have had van halen opening
for
them and so you know these established
bands
give give a possibility for these
younger bands to
um to circulate to get their sound out
there
[Music]
so i'll read andy's thing but before
that scott
you're you're uh don't forget um but
when randy rhodes died
uh before jakey lee brad gillis he he
got brad gillis
who was from night ranger um do you know
how that happened
at all or actually brad told me
he well tell us um
i guess um after that happened
um uh maybe sharon got on the phone and
they were they were uh they went to l.a
they were uh
brad the night ranger brad's from san
francisco but you know he was
in l.a and they said we need we need a
hot guitar player to like finish this
tour
and that's where speaker the devil came
from but um
he said he actually was he didn't
believe it but he was asked by
he got a call from ozzy thought one of
his friends was putting him on with him
you know and he said just come with your
guitar to this
you know to my hotel and it turned out
to be one of those huge suites
in fact i can't picture it but he said
there was like an upstairs to it
and so he went ozzy was pretty drunk
there was a ton of people there he said
he went upstairs and he goes just play
me something so he goes i was playing
like
the crazy train solo i was playing like
everything
and he just you know got all teared up
and he he said
he took me and and went to the top of
the stairs like he's making this big
announcement to everybody
everybody i found my new guitarist then
he said it was just that he goes i
auditioned with him
like in a bedroom like at a party
so um and then i think you know after
that tour finished you know he had
obligations with night ranger
yeah but uh but it was kind of a cool
story like
you know yeah i mean oh come on who is
this
you know you do a good aussie
impersonation
i mean it goes it goes to show these
these um these british bands and british
let's call them big actors in it they
could they could draw on the talent pool
in la a lot of a lot of women come from
other places like you mentioned
um other places in california a lot of
new york people went out to la
as well i mean you see this with like um
uh lemmy you know after fast eddie goes
he's got to recruit people
um yeah where does he do well he hangs
out at the rainbow
and he was a big staple with the rainbow
he was always on the boat
yeah so andy says i think the fact greg
is wearing his kiss army t-shirt as
proof that the desire to belong never
goes away
well i wanted to wear it of course
because i'm making the case that kisses
metals
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't say you're
wrong i mean but here's
i mean let's put something if we're
having this discussion in 1978
oh interesting like who's heavy metal in
78 you mean yeah
we would say kiss but but this day and
age we look back and go that's not heavy
metal anymore
because things have gotten so and we
have norwegian death metal bands that
are actually gangs
we have you know um black metal we have
oh there's too many
all the different genres yeah yeah and
so
i think some of these things that were
metal and and astonishing at the time to
people
um now is maybe classical and that's the
reason like if we
if you and i it was 1978 it was they
were they were outrageous
you know and i don't know was that like
even a term back then what do we call
bands back then
i mean you know in the 70s before look
we have to realize is gone are the days
where
the record companies and the record
stores demand you tell what it is
because they had to know where to file
the album right so there's a map there's
a metal section at like newbury comic
for us
there's a rock section there's a blue
section there's a jazz section
there's a connection where do you fit in
and then you have to label yourself
libraries still have have uh things like
that but they don't have metal sections
it's just in the the general rock right
which is differentiating
they're pressing metal heads yeah yeah i
mean it's kind of funny because you look
at like itunes
or now it's apple music and they have
some stuff in there that's labeled
metal and you're like well that's not
metal at all you know and then there's
all sorts of like classic metal bands
that are just hard rock you know or just
rock
mark says something interesting i've
heard metalheads tell uh tell me iron
maiden isn't
metal but so here's it's probably
somebody younger
probably somebody that's listening to
something so heavy
i mean some of the stuff my students
bring in
i just i mean we way beyond cookie
monster
and um so distorted so fast
no form to the tunes which but that's
part of the charm for it i guess
i mean i guess if they're hearing a song
with structure
that's not very metal these days so
that's why we say like if we had this
discussion in 1980
or 1990 would we answer these questions
differently
yeah there was i mean there's a
narrative
out there that i think is a wrong-headed
narrative and we're having these
sessions in part to like you know fill
in the gaps
and it's you can find it in some um
some books about metal and the idea is
well black sabbath created it there was
proto metal but we don't really care
about them
and then it was you know sort of a a
wasteland and then judas priest came on
the scene in the mid 70s
and it was still you know like a
wasteland and then it blew up with the
new wave of british heavy metal
which we'll cover a bit you know um and
that's
and then we jump into like all the
genres and the genres are where the real
action is and you're like and i did i've
done some book reviews of some of these
in different places and i've been like
they
here's a here's an important band they
skipped right over you know why
why aren't they in there the the story
is
you know the story should be way fatter
from 70 to
85 than it is but a lot of the the
people who are into this
um and i think the the music scholars
who are pushing this
and also should say rob halford
oftentimes talks this way when he's
giving his talks
during during a priest thing because
it's kind of self-serving
they push this narrative in part because
you know there's
it gives you a different thing where you
can look back
and look back from the the present or
the
you know early pat or the past that's
not that far from you
of being in this genre you know of being
into folk metal
and it's not just folk metal but it's
scandinavian folk metal you know
or pirate metal or this metal and you
know you you look at that and you're
like well that's
those are all like legitimate um things
but they're all not all i i don't wanna
it's because
power metal doom metal um
you know original black metal those are
those are
like bigger genres you can say um
but they're presented as if they're all
like on the same plane
as far as the importance of it whereas
um
i don't think that's the case i think
when you when you look at it from like
the back end
and how things developed you get a
better picture
you know yeah a truer
oh i'm sorry what i was going to say a
truer picture you know
yeah so there's one other band i was
going to ask you about
uh in terms of are they metal or not and
i think they aren't but
it's kind of interesting to to speculate
because you did have at least one member
who then played an important role in the
the metal scene in the 80s the runaways
oh rock right yeah joan jett who is sort
of metal adjacent
and lita ford who certainly positioned
herself as
metal right well joan jett joan jett is
i call i my own thing i call that cbgb
rock like this and i'm referring to the
york city
so um it's it's the runaways were rock
and roll but
punk in their edge
and joan jett wasn't metal i mean like
you know
her albums are all cover tunes bad
reputation that's a cover tune
up rock and roll that's an old cover
tune um and the riffs the riffs for all
those are very straightforward and
simple
too you know yeah they're right yeah and
i've seen her many times and she's a
rock goddess i love her but
the only thing with lita ford is yeah
she did
i mean like kissing is her stuff really
metal no
that was a pop tune but you know what
gave her medals when she did that song
with ozzy remember what you did close my
eyes forever with ozzy i think that's
what
made people go oh and then i remember at
the time people weren't aware of the
runaways like they're like lead a fourth
it's new
um but the runaways yeah i wouldn't say
they're
i would contrast them with with two
british bands from the new wave of
british heavy metal
girl school you know who had all these
connections with motorhead
and uh who are definitely metal and then
rock goddess
a trio who um one one of them was
actually too young to play in clubs and
was was doing it illegally when when
they were
uh doing it very early 80s right then
they kind of and they're both still out
there
producing music um
as a matter of fact there was some
overlap if i remember right like one of
the members of girl school
later on played in rock goddess
so clearly metal runaways
no but you know if you listen to all
this other stuff you probably did hear
cherry bomb
you know yeah i mean all that stuff it
was it was rock and roll
you know some of it was kind of
anthematic but like you know that was
best heard in beer soaked clubs you know
and i mean that in the best way it's
like it's such a vibe
and that's one of the funny things about
criteria that we've talked about in the
past it's kind of like
okay if you're in a metal band like
let's say mega death
you you it's kind of it's a kind of
metal band that um
you really need to be in tune right like
you know like if you're
right but then i always say to my
students well is it a deal breaker if
you're
watching the runaways in 1978 on a hot
august night
and they're they're on fire but joan
jets b
string slightly flat is that gonna ruin
the night for you or is that part of the
yeah the charm to what you're hearing
and i would say it's part of the charm
is that it's a little out it's a little
angsty it's a little
um so yeah i i think even you know when
you talk about
criteria that matters in musical terms
one of them i use is
well if it's really in tune is it is it
or if it's a little out of tune
is it gonna be a deal breaker well in
these instances yes
yeah in these instances no so
any information being in tune the
instrument like you know have people
playing in tune
so andy's got a question about somebody
who i again i remember seeing
ads for her stuff a lot like in circus
and hit parader in the 80s
what about [ __ ] the band that was
fronted by
uh i don't remember her last name but
betsy
female singer and then there were um
sort of like
in some respects we could also ask a
similar question about like you know
wendy williams and the plasmatics right
um oh that's a good show there we go i
don't think that was her real last name
but
you know good stage name you never know
yeah yeah that's true and you know i've
listened to it and it's it's metal
it's not like top tier metal the the
backup band isn't
isn't really that that great um
but i think they you know they did have
like she points out the s m
angle um a lot of the songs are are
focused on that
that sort of thing um are they met well
chris morrissey weighs in [ __ ] is metal
so
yeah uh susie quattro that's another
good
good example um and and we could
actually do a thing on like women in
metal
sometime that and not just like women in
metal because
there's so many now um we'd almost get
like deluged with it but but who is
actually
um doing stuff and not getting
recognized for it
um or the pioneers like i just want to
interject that
at burke they have there's in the last
15 years there's a lot of
a lot more female electric rock guitar
players
and um i think when i you know started
teaching
in the late 80s i was still in my teens
no female was really playing rock guitar
it wasn't because their
mothers told them that wasn't feminine
that wasn't so
i tend to ask you know who are some of
the people you look up to
and i'm always kind of curious to like
understand
why it's okay now um which i think it is
it's great well you've people like
um well you go back to the runaways
actually with that in my opinion
um and uh but like you know a lot of
them go out and become
great rock players in their own right
with with good careers
it's something new so that the reason i
bring that up is
that's actually uh would be worth the
show is kind of like
the the history of that and how you know
uh
women came into being really
valuable in rock where even now you go
to metal shows and there are women there
like you know back in the day
it was a spinal attack joke right like
it was no women would go there it's all
predominantly young boys you know but
that was kind of true
but i've gone to maiden shows and
pre-shows and there's a lot of women
there
and um so it's like them accepting the
medal maybe
you know it was maybe the social uh this
the social part of it i don't know
but i do notice um there's a progression
and
a lot of these go to heavy metal they're
not like
there's some blues but like a lot of the
female students i have
become prague metal or heavy metal which
is
pretty cool i mean is that in part
because it's technically more demanding
do you think or so there's more room to
like grow
you know well i don't i don't want to
put down the blues but
i mean you can get better at the blues
over over time that's a lifetime if you
really
you know um you know i mean unless you
like you were
born like albert king and came up that
way but we don't really
especially people like me from the
suburbs you know um
you can't there's degrees of good blues
players um
but um i don't you know that's a good
question and that's something i might
ask like what
drew you to play math rock is which is a
genre
um which is basically making things
complicated
time wise you know we'll have a measure
of 13 and then we're going to subdivide
this
the dave rubex of rock right
oh dave brubeck is is too simple for
that but
um it's it's it it the idea behind it is
to like
have mathematical like you know we're
gonna have this many hits here and here
and here
um it's yeah i mean but um
i don't know i think it's i think it's
okay i don't know if it's a
society thing and this is something i
should ask because
um now it's okay for these very feminine
looking women
to appear aggressive and really
express themselves in the metal genre
which is
probably really liberating for all of us
you know but like
it was something that like we didn't see
really in high school i didn't see that
in high school
as a guitar player if i was a rock
player it was you know
although most of the women played
acoustic guitar
um which there's nothing wrong with i'm
just thinking now it's like wow like
if you if you went in a time machine
back like what would people think in
1982
i mean the runaways were pretty you know
they were they were gutsy
yeah now we don't think of them as gutsy
but to get out there
you know they were popular but maybe the
hate they got or the bullying they got
or the
uh they were they're truly pioneers well
that's something that they do talk
quite a bit about um not the runaways
and such but others that i'm thinking
about like like
you know members of girls school like
kim mcauliffe
about just like the routine [ __ ]
they had to put up with all the time
right and um i mean being associated
with somebody like lemmy would actually
keep
some of the the skeevy guys off of your
back
i think yeah sure yeah so absolutely
well well let's take a few more
questions or
comments or stuff like that and um
[Music]
then we'll bring it to a wrap because i
know we're oh wow we're way way over
time
so any anything else anybody wants to to
bring up
i just wanted uh it was rare even when i
was in high school
it's a recent change in perception yeah
and um
you know it's hard to ask just to
expound on that
it's hard to ask any of my current
students because they don't have a
perspective
they weren't alive in this even the 90s
um yeah so it's kind of like they were
they're
born into an era where the path was
already
kind of drawn enough so they were
it was acceptable for them to be there i
guess i guess
in the discussion it would be kind of
like well who
who made this ex who made this
acceptable in others who blazed the
trail
yeah who empowered you know who
empowered um
anyone you know to like go into this or
that
um because so socially things change
over time and music is part of that
breathing
uh you know uh well we're talking about
genres now
like i said 78 kiss would have to be
super metal
you know but that's before norwegian
death metal and black metal and speed
metal and
math metal and so yeah different genres
yeah
well let's you know we want to be
respectful of people's time
thanks again scott for for joining i
really appreciate it you always have so
much to
contribute to this it's fun to geek out
over all these things thanks to
everybody for
joining us and for your questions
comments insights and all of that
um next time we're probably going to be
doing some more music stuff and i think
we'll
we'll focus on the la scene and there's
a whole bunch of different bands to talk
about but we've laid some really good
ground work for for that
absolutely all right well
i'm going to wish everybody a great day
uh mark over in south africa
great uh evening it's got to be oh yeah
late now so good to see you chris
uh and um we'll we'll you know we'll be
talking about some more stuff next next
month
awesome thanks everyone
you